first of all it is so good to see you
two back on the screen
as siblings once again
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute so we are playing
siblings i mean because the press
release said that you were hustling
exactly you know i had to double check
on that because i was a bit confused but
then i watched the film
and i was like okay so this one could
ever see us as anything other than
siblings
before we dive deeper into youtube
playing brother and sister again
tell us about christmas in carolina
so we got a call from stacy davis who is
the writer of christmas in carolina
and my father and my stepmother and i
are partners in dream merchant media
which is a production company and we
look to go directly the movie as well
pet peg co-director directed the movie
as well
um and uh it was just a family affair we
had darius in it the guy who played
waldo on the show he helped to direct it
as well
really shawn harrison you have brilliant
writer
brilliant um um you know just some
production tip it was really cool we got
a great chemistry
the three of us anyway he's an awesome
acting coach and you know kelly helped
keep me in line
um i mean i was in the middle of this
that's a full-time job it
i do that when we're not taping too yeah
you do you do i was in the middle of
having a baby it was it was
dramatic it was crazy i had to leave
such a great performer you have to deal
with it
well this was literally a family matter
situation right
and we do we enjoy being together it
doesn't matter if it's a
barbecue or if i invite somebody to come
and be in a
film that i'm producing it's just so
good
i enjoy seeing him we have such a good
time together
yes always well you two you two played
siblings
for almost a decade until family matters
ended
in 1998. so how does it feel to be back
together again i know you all
communicate often obviously but to be
back
working together side by side how was
that
i mean it's awesome it's like riding a
bike like kelly said
um whether it's i mean i i would party
with with kelly
and sean and jaleel i partied with them
in a phone booth
so you know it didn't matter you give us
some space and
we're really all over the place so we
have we had a really good time and it's
like we just fall right back into it the
chemistry is always there
kelly is so good um i mean she's just so
good
um when it comes to being generous um
when it comes to knowing what you need
uh it's just so easy it's like it's a
no-brainer it's like muscle memory
so you know um it can show up and
and be the characters and these
characters are different they're not
eddie and laura
they're different right um you know so
uh
for most it probably would be a
challenge but when you have that kind of
chemistry
it's like riding a bike yeah a
well-oiled bike
so we didn't get season 10 where laura
and steve were supposed to get married
right is there any hope for a revival
or a reboot where you all are grown you
have your lives now
we see steve and laura together i'm
gonna defer to kelly i cannot continue
and i was gonna say
let darius darius's friends is bffs with
jaleel so
he would have to explain that all i must
say is that we are working on some
things
um but the public doesn't need to
understand it is not doing it
so no but no is that official
this deeper no it's deeper than that we
don't own
these characters you don't own the
property and so there are some things
that we have to
uh to do legally to make sure that you
know that
we will be able to give you what you
want but the bottom line is
uh they own family matters they don't
own us
so you know you can get ready for the
picky picky picky remix
hey girl felicia you gotta pray for us
here
right cause this man is crazy but but
look people probably if you do it right
people won't be
mad at it but that's devastating kind of
because i came in here thinking that
there might be a possibility
it's not us we don't we don't know we
don't hold the ip let's go
and keep it real we don't own the iep
however we do own ourselves
and there are some things that we're
talking about we talk about it all the
time you know kelly and i we talk
you know weekly um uh you know uh jay
and i
we talk quite often um i mean i just
talked to him maybe last week
um and so there are some things in the
works and you know
jay has has told me you know he's out of
his mouth whatever it is
that that that i'm doing we do it so i
mean that's one that's my brother from
another mother like kelly said
and as long as kelly you know and uh you
know
cherries them when everybody's down
there's always a possibility that you
guys can see us
together again so we always love being
with each other that's why i invited
darius on this
so we may not be on family matters
together but right projects together
all the time right okay okay i'm not mad
at that
and used to experience that same
chemistry right
yeah you brought up ownership which i
think is just a
really important conversation especially
when it comes to the black community
so i want to tie that into my next
question absolutely
family matters you know was one of the
longest running
african-american focus sitcoms on
television
how do you think this show influenced
what we see
on tv today tremendously
i mean tremendously um one of my
favorite statements i hear from anybody
is when someone says to me
oh that is not of uh of color
says to me you know this show really did
wonders for
shaping uh my perception of
the african-american experience and i
was at a point in my life where i could
have gone either way
and this showed me how black people
lived and i was able to relate
to you all as just people versus black
people
you know and so it gave me a solid
example to stand on and i'm different
today because of the show
you know um and so i think that that was
one of the greatest things that tom
involved under the greatest
all the work that they've done that's
little horos in texas perfect strangers
full house
all the work that they've done um
getting by all the work that they've
done
i think that that was one of the most
important things bill bickley michael
warren
one of the greatest things they could
have ever done was give a black family
to america
right and and to piggyback off of that
darius
that's the thing that's the thing i
think that is
most significant about the show is that
the producers made a show about a family
it wasn't about a black family
specifically we just happened to be
black people but the things that went on
on the show
they were universal anybody can identify
with the things that
we spoke about we talked about we spoke
about uh police brutality
back then that was profiling all of that
yeah
right so i i think it was uh novel
because
we we aim to
be palatable to everybody
right yeah and we talked about how
others
see black people how it influence how
others see black people but how do you
think it influenced how black people see
themselves
the show uh
we were always very conscious of that
because we wanted to represent
the black experience in a real way we
weren't like
uh overly
you know wealthy we just wanted to have
a real family just like
all in the family and all of those they
weren't the thing that made them
extraordinary was that they were
ordinary these were ordinary people
doing blue collar collar things
yeah and uh we just wanted to
shine the light on the everyday every
man you know
and uh so i think it it helped to see
it help people to see african americans
in a way that
is just like them yeah yeah who
experience the same things as them
you know see black nerds
that's important that's very important
that was a good point all right one more
question before i let you all go
any behind the scenes moments from your
days on family matters that
fans might not know any that
if you want additional other than the
time that darius put vaseline on my
toilet seat
why did you do that
why hey kelly kelly come on now
how did you know that that was me did i
how do you know
it could have been hold me by laughing
was this before was this before you had
to shoot when was
when was this during rehearsals he would
sneak into our dressing rooms
he was horrible he was a horrible
trickster
people loved the show because they think
it was you know we were such a
you know it was a real family he was a
real big brother
an annoying brother
why did you do that what was your
thought process behind putting vaseline
on here what did you think
see what would happen i mean another
great trick you guys
were watching some of you that might
want to get an impression put saran wrap
over the bowl see what i did that way it
really got bright
inappropriate
inappropriate
oh my goodness
maple syrup or the doorknob is really
good too
maple syrup works really well that's 41
of you next time
oh sir you're 40 something years old
get a life love you two together oh my
goodness you're such a joy
everybody has to make sure to check out
christmas in carolina november 1st
on digital and demand
you